but it's great because you want to feel
a part of something that people want to
see and people care about you know and
these fans really care about what we're
trying to do here so it's some that's
only a good thing you know do you know
the funds I mean it means so much in
this book has transcended like so many
other books in terms of what it means to
fans and high tax they are to these
characters you know so we felt that we
really just had to try to honor that as
much as we good about but also you know
try to make a great picture I mean
that's essentially want to make a great
movie but also to please all the fans
and I I think we've done that yeah that
was a bit of a shocker to say that and
she'll walk in there theatre and just
yeah the response and you know that's a
good room to be in you know they're like
hardcore fans in there so it's nice to
sort of even feel a little bit of that
you know and that energy rubs off on you
a bit and that's exciting I just you
know just that its realize you know that
that you know pictures with visual right
we all read books and we all have an
idea of what they're going to be like
and we're playing them on her head and
we're casting them and everything so
it's just exciting to be able to be part
of the thing that you know we have
created our best version of what they
want you know and and that's just a
really cool thing and I just I'm just so
excited for them to see you know
you